at CFR we see research differently it's  about more than proximity and  disciplines it's about asking the big  questions and assembling the right teams  to find answers being bold and taking  risks supporting diverse researchers who  achieve unprecedented advances in life  and health for individuals and society  for Earth and space for information and  matter for the world  we support the risk takers we enable big  thinking we bring together the brightest  and boldest minds across academic  disciplines and across borders to  address science and humanity's most  important questions together we stay  curious and we will continue to provide  researchers with the time and freedom to  explore new ideas as we look to the  future we will work from this premise  fundamental research matters some of it  changes what we know about the world  today and some of it will change what we  know centuries from now all of it fuels  innovation and advances humankind join  us  you  [Music]